in fact when he does those things people
freaked out kids make fun of you you're
an immigrant you're poor winnings easy
and I said I'll make a profit and all
these other things they said no my dad
works in a factory sweeping floors and
my mom's our receptionist people
overcomplicate business and success I
always say to people I'm not in business
for emotional gratification if you drop
me in the middle of the jungle
I'll figure out a way to survive as you
forget a lot of money part why were we
put on this earth
he's a Croatian born Canadian
businessman author investor and TV
personality Herjavec group was one of
Canada's fastest growing technology
companies he has an estimated net worth
of 200 million dollars he's Robert
Herjavec and here are his top 10 rules
for success you have to be passionate
about one thing be great at one thing
the world will reward your knowledge of
a very narrow field so the analogy
always used is you know Tom Brady I love
NFL football Tom Brady gets paid 25
million dollars a year to throw the ball
he doesn't get paid to block he doesn't
get paid to tackle in fact when he does
those things people freaked out be Tom
Brady be good it we could have my name
at one thing and then be great at that
one thing be world-class at one thing
forget your weaknesses because somebody
is going to eat your lunch at the stuff
you're not good at I'm a pretty happy
guy yeah you know I think that's one of
the keys to success I read an article
that the difference between successful
people and people that struggle are
successful people exude joy Jeff if
you're not a happy guy and other people
don't want to hang out right why would
they hang out with right if you're
miserable and nobody wants to spend time
with you how are you ever gonna get
ahead yeah it like complain I remember
when we were really young this lesson
was taught to me by my dad and I kind of
had a miserable day at school because
you know the kids make fun of you you're
an immigrant you're poor and I came home
and I was feeling sorry for myself and
my dad came home it's gonna sound so
melodramatic he walked a couple miles to
the factory I was a blue-collar guy and
I came home he just stood there and I
was complaining about my day where were
you living we were living
like a and oh this stage would be three
times the size and a little Carson
there's him oh my gosh oh it wasn't it
wasn't Pleasant and my dad was just
stand there and I was complaining and
feeling sorry for myself and my dad
looks at me and says never complain you
should always be happy with the
opportunities given you and that was it
and so you you know you feel that fit
you know every time you lose at
something you're one step close to
winning the next time the difference
between successful people are not
successful people okay let's call it
that ray are people give up people wake
up every morning have doubt they have
fear they lose in a Ferrari race or
they're losing a race and then they just
give up the the hardest thing in life to
learn is to lose winning is easy you win
you're happy you get a high five your
friends are happy it's your ability to
take a loss get up the next day dust
yourself off and keep going I have lost
that everything you can imagine
seriously we have I have been beat up
and put down and everything that can go
wrong has gone wrong for me but I I just
kept going I used to work for Warren
Davis the guy who started Avis
rent-a-car and he said to me one day
Robert what's the purpose of business
and I said oh make a profit and all
these other things they said no the
purpose of business is to create a
customer because everything else takes
care of itself if you can create
customers and create value for them
because the answer that question is
different for every single customer then
you're gonna have a great business you
know it's funny when I was growing up
everybody said that to me it's not what
you know it's who you know
is that true so that well so there I am
I'm 18 years old my dad works in a
factory sweeping floors and my mom's our
receptionist so if the key to success in
life is who you know I I'm in trouble so
I said to myself I don't believe that I
believe I got to go out and become the
guy that others want to get to know it's
all about what you make of it
and you listen to what you call your
spidey senses or your spider senses your
intuition all the time have you always
always always I learned that from my
parents because I don't have a fancy
education we didn't have fancy advisors
the most successful person I knew
growing up was my dad's boss and that
was only because he had more seniority
in the Union than my dad so you've got
to learn to listen to yourself
people overcomplicate business and
success people are watching right now
and say oh I can't do what he does
because I don't know how to run a
business everybody has the ability you
just got to listen to yourself that's
hard to do very because you get the
message and it's unemotional and you
think I know you have to listen to your
senses when you're on an elevator big
hefty guy gets on as a female get off
right right no matter if your intuition
is right just get off the elevator it's
it's fear I think most people are
blinded by fear and to be successful at
anything you've got to be able to
control that and work your way through
it
I always say to people I'm not in
business for emotional gratification I'm
in business to to make money and build a
great company and all these other things
so you got to leave your emotion out of
it because when you're angry or you hate
you make stupid decisions but that
doesn't mean you have to become a jerk
or mean about it I mean nobody likes to
do business with somebody who isn't nice
to draw on other people's experiences
they don't seem to relate to your life
George st. Pierre MMA fighter what does
a businessman learn from a guy who
punches people for a living
wow we're just talking about that
outside and you know difference between
the UFC fighter and the rest of us is no
one hits us in the face every morning so
that that really brings things into
focus what I learned out of him is it's
all about being efficient it's not the
strong it's not the big it's not the
rich it's not the poor they'll inherit
that earth it'll be the efficient you
don't see too many dinosaurs walking
around
more and they were really big animals
yeah yeah so okay great so not being a
dinosaur is an important lesson so how
do you adaptability adaptability so I've
never been the smartest guy in the room
but I feel pretty confident if you drop
me in the middle of a jungle I'll figure
out a way to survive it's your ability
to survive in any situation that
separates the people that do well from
those that don't I think you've got to
find what makes you tick and I think
greatness comes from when you marry your
passion with your job because I don't
really think I have a job I just I love
what I do and I always say that to kids
I talk to a lot of kids for a university
and say how do I make a lot of money and
so forget the lot of money part find
something you're going to be great at
and let the money follow you so what
what is it about people who find their
passion who work hard and never make a
dime well they make a few dimes but not
enough they never get there you know if
any it's it's interesting because we
have this conversation all the time I
live in a very affluent area and I have
these quarterly dinners or used to with
my neighbors so at one point I had
twenty guys they were all worth hundreds
of millions of dollars and we asked that
same question can you always be
successful even if you love what you do
and all the other stuff and the reality
is as my dad said if you work hard right
you will never be poor in life but just
because you work hard doesn't mean
you'll be rich sometimes you need to get
lucky but but the reality is that the
harder you work it true the luckier you
get because people always think there's
a finality to success you know people
think about success in terms of a finish
line people was asked me why are you so
successful and I always crack them and I
say I'm not successful you know the
minute you think you've made it is the
beginning of the end so it's just about
the overall message is you got to keep
going you got to love what you do and
you got to keep going
why
because what's the alternative what's
the alternative
why were we put on this earth where we
put on this earth to be miserable and to
complain and and to look at life as
victims I am in control of everything
that happens to everything everything
that will happen in my life I will be
the master of that doesn't mean my life
will always be happy that doesn't mean
my life will always be good but I have
the ultimate choice to choose how I will
react to the things that happen to me
and move forward from that and I'm okay
with not succeeding at them because the
journey on that road is worth it for me
thank you so much for watching I made
this video because povery Roth asked me
to so there's a famous entrepreneur that
you want me to profile next leave it in
the comments below and I'll see what I
can do
I'd also love to know which of Robert
Herjavec top 10 rules meant the most to
you leave it in the comments and I'll
join the discussion thank you so much
for watching continue to believe and
I'll see you soon